それから仏教的な稼ぎ方
稼がなくてはならない業の生まれなので
稼ぐことに文句を言えないんですね
仏教徒は稼ぐことには何の文句も言わない
何のこともなく仕事して稼ぐんです
特に真面目な仏教徒であると欲がないんですよ
ほとんど 欲もなく怒りもなく
すごく穏やかにいるんですけど
仕事だけはしっかりするんです
本当に真面目にブッダの教えを信仰している
実行実践している人だったら
もう仕事の方がもうどんどん寄ってくるんですよ
その人は金欲しい 金欲しい
金持ちと思ってないんですよ
すごくニコニコと頼まれる仕事をちゃんとやってあげたりする
すごい関係 環境 関係と環境がうまくいくんですよ
在家も出家も仕事をしなければならないんです
だって生きてるものは全部仕事をしなくちゃあかんだから
しかし 在家の場合は稼ぐことも仕事の一部なのです
出家は稼ぐということをしてはいけないんです
それは肉体に対する欲になるんだから
で 在家の場合は仕事もしなくちゃいけないし
稼ぎもしなくちゃいけないんです
仏教的な稼ぎ方というのは簡単です
欲を満たせません ネセシティーという必需
必要性 欲求を満たす いわゆる欲求を満たす
欲望は満たせません 思い耽くない
妄想して ああいう風にこういう風になりたいとか
そういう思うこともさえしない
ただ必要なことだけ 欲求だけ満たしてあげる
そういうシンプルな生き方なんです
だから この最後のこれですべて言えると思います
食のことを常に念頭に置いておく
仏教徒なら あの いつでも食の考え方はね
常に念頭に入れておくんです
何で稼ぐのかというと
やっぱり食が必要ですよ
これが自分の能力で儲けなくちゃいけないんだと知っているんです
楽しみも快楽も理性的なリミットにする
あの仏教徒も楽しみを探すんですよ
快楽も探すんですよ でもリミットがあるんですね
例えば家族で楽しい 不倫はしませんと
いつでもちゃんとリミットをつけておくんです
稼ぐことは人生の目的ではありません
今 現代社会人にとっては
稼ぐことが哲学であって
人生の目的のすべてでしょうに
だから会社をもう退職すると
もうもう生きがいも全部なくなっちゃうんですね
すごい情けない状態になるんですよ
仏教徒にとっては これ人生の一部やることだから
ずっと人生生まれてから死ぬまで系の計画なんです
だからまあ それもよく理解しておいて
目的ではありませんと
やらなくてはならない仕事の一部だけです
稼ぎっていうのはやらなくてはいけないことの一部ですよ
すべてじゃない 命を張って死の覚悟で仕事をするほど無知ではありません
仏教徒が 命を張って仕事するバカもいますからね
死ぬ覚悟です なんだそれと思いますけど
それから才能を生かせる仕事を選ぶんですよ
やりたい仕事と何とかではなくて
自分を持っている才能を生かせる方で仕事をするんです
そんなところでしょうね
それから仏教的な稼ぎ方でも
怠けないという怠けたいけないということは
すごく派手にお釈迦様おっしゃっているんです
労働減ることばかり考えてはならないんです
大体みんな怠けてもう労働減ることばっかり
手抜くことばっかり考えているんです
だから三菱なんとか あれもトラブルを起こしたし
もうすごい大変なことになるんですよ
なんとか太陽村じゃなくて
なんとかの村で あの 放射事故ね
え？ウランがなんかね
爆発して大変なことになったでしょうし
手抜くんだからいいんです
労働力減らそうとかね
自分の能力によって重労働の仕事しかない場合もありますよ
ある人々にはもう重労働するしかないんです
そういう業の場合もありますよ
仏教徒なら 自分には自分がすごく重労働で稼がなくちゃいけないなとわかったら
何の文句も言わないで
私は勉強できないわ もう事務所で何かオフィスレディーとかね
事務員の仕事を そんな能力はないし
文字なんか読みたくもないんだぞとかね
わかりませんと 計算もできませんと
だからいいんじゃないか
私はもう肉体を張って仕事をするんだと
すごい楽しくやるん 自分の仕事は
要は収入が足りるか 良い結果を出せるかないかですよ
仏教徒なら考えるのは
自分にはこの生活 基本的な生活を維持するために収入は足りるかないかと
足らないんだったらちょこちょこと整理整頓しなくちゃいけない
しかし 欲望を満たすだったらもうダメですよ
欲望を満たすではなくて
必需品を揃う こんな仕事では揃いませんよと思ったら
仕事を変えなくちゃいけない
ちょっとペースを調整しなくちゃいけない
必ずもう揃いますよ 必需品は
業がそうなってます 業では
揃わないはずがないんです
それでマッジム・ニカーヤの九十九番目
仕事の価値は労働量ではなく結果であると説かれています
この経典で面白いエピソードがあって
このあるバラモン人がお釈迦様にケチをつけたんですよ
あなた方は出家はすごい楽々やと
仕事をしないんだと 家族もないんだから何の問題もないんだと
だからまあ あんた方も幸せにいることは確かでしょうし
しかし 在家の人々は朝から晩まで仕事をして
家族を守って それから使用人やらそういう人々にも給料を払って
ものすごい重労働ですよと
複雑ですよと 大変だよと
だから出家より在家の方が価値ありますよと
褒めるべきだよ と言ったんです
でお釈迦様の答えは そういう違いには言いませんよと
お釈迦様はたとえで答えたんですよ
例えば農業がある 農業っていうのは仕事多い
労働力は多い しかし うまくいったら結構な収入だよと
それでまた 農業の場合は
仕事を労働力がものすごいあって苦しいんだけど
もしうまくいかなかったらどうなるのかというと
ものすごい最悪だと 収穫がなかったらわからないでしょうね
虫に食われるわ 雨が降らなくなるわ
あるいは台風で流されるわ
どうなるかわからない
だから農業の場合 素晴らしいと一概に言えませんよ
うまく行くと結構な収入になる
うまくいかないと もう苦しみのどん底だと
次に商売どうでしょうか
商売っていうのは労働力はないんだと
すごい単純シンプルだと
だけど皆様怒るかもしれませんが
商売もそう単純じゃないんだと
それは頭が悪いだけであって
商売っていうのはすごい単純シンプルですよ
誰かが作った品物をいくらか利益を足して売るだけのことでしょう
そんなに能力はいらん
まあそろばんできないとね
それで商売は 労働力は少ないし
もしうまくいったらかなりお金になるんだよと
その場合はいいんだと
商売が仕事量が少ないんだけど
うまくいかなかったらものすごい赤字になるんだよと
ちょっと試しに考えてください
あの花とかね 例えば百万円ぐらいの花いっぱい買ってしまったと
1週間以内に売れなかったら
あの百万も全部 赤字でしょう
もう立ち上がれなくなっちゃうんです
そういうわけで どんな仕事偉いかっていうのはありませんと
結果で考えなさいよと
それで出家するお釈迦様は自分の立場をそれから我々は労働力は少ないかもしれませんだけど
我々はこういうことを求めている
こういうことを求めている
こういうことを求めているんだと
ずっと仏教的な精神的な覚悟をする
教訓を説明してあげて
あんた方にはその結果のね
億分の1もないでしょうと
だから最大の結果を出してるんだから
私たちの方が優れてるんだ
その上 仕事量も少ないんだ
ということで分析してあげたんですよ
だから仏教的に見ると
まあ結果で考えればいいんですよ
良い結果が出るならば
労働も悪くない リストラになる恐れ
毎日だったらね 会社で
ね 机に向かって毎日悶々と仕事したってもね
怯えてビクビクして 全部結果ですよ
生 まあ労働力 いろいろ手抜きしてはいけないということで
怠けに陥るものは １ とても寒い
あるいは２ とても暑い
あるいは遅すぎ 午後のことで
トゥライトのことで あるいは朝だったら早すぎ
お腹が空いている 今は満腹だとか
何とか言って仕事をしないんですよ
なんとかなんとかいう
それは経典の訳で もっといいわけは今の人々は言うんですよ
サボる 仕事をサボるものには財産が生まれません
ある財産も消えていく
これは全部経典の訳なんです
これもこのように怠けることに端緒が 6つです
これディグニカのこの場所にあるんです
これはお釈迦様の言葉です
怠けるなよと 言い訳言うなよと
仕事も稼ぎも その時その時やらなくちゃいけないんです
怠け人にとってはなんでもいいんですよ
もう怠けるために はい
それからちょっとテーマ少々変えますので
ちょっと 10 分ぐらい休憩いたします
はい